foreign
[Music]
for inviting me to share our experience
with the clinical development of
medicinal signaling cells for liver
regenerative medicine I am attempt SoCal
I am professor of medicine at UC Louvre
University in Belgium and I am a CEO of
a spin-off company called celayon
so the story started quite a while ago I
I was and I am still a nepatologist a
liver doctor and I am used to do liver
transplantation but liver
transplantation is always a bit
frustrating because you have to remove
the whole liver to replace with a new
liver what we wanted to do is to repair
the liver and to restart the functioning
normally and this is particularly the
case for children with inborn error of
metabolism because there is one single
missing enzyme and the rest of the liver
is perfect so we started to do what is
called hepatocyte transplantation it
means that
instead of replacing the full liver you
are just infusing liver cells in the
existing organ to bring the missing
enzyme activity and the first one was
done in 2001 this was the first the
pathosite transplantation in Europe and
it was in a child with a very very rare
disease
peroxidomile disorders but it went well
and it was successful and what we could
see in this patient is that there was an
improvement of the circulating
metabolites your liver is really the
Machinery that is processing everything
in your body this child had a missing
enzyme because of that yet abnormal
metabolites accumulating and being toxic
for his brain eyes and ears and thanks
to the hepatocyte infused in his own
liver there was an improvement and as
you see the colon there was a first
Improvement due to the mass of cell
between d0 and D6 but after that there
was some kind of of relapse due to The
Disappearance of hepatocyte which were
not successfully and grafted but
thereafter there was a progressive
Improvement due to the encampment and
even proliferation of
transplanted hepatocyte so this was
really exciting and we started of course
to treat other patients with inborn
error of metabolism these were patients
with
urea cycle disorder the
urea cycle disorders you do not possess
ammonium properly you do not synthetize
urea and we could see that by infusing
hepatocyte we had an improvement in the
urea synthesis besides that we could
also demonstrate engraftment in the
liver of this patient and we could see
appearance of denovo enzyme activity we
could detect donor cells by fish
technique for the Y chromosome and we
could measure a progressive increasing
enzyme activity from zero percent
progressively to three to four percent
and this is a huge difference between
zero percent and four percent it
modifies completely the phenotype of the
disease it brings you to a normal uh
near normal phenotype although you still
are at risk of decompensation in severe
situation but no more in a daily life
so that was very successful the
inconvenience is that you need to infuse
the cells in the liver of the patient so
you need to access the liver by
percutaneous root in the portal vein
this vein is really difficult to access
because it is located between the gut
and the liver so that was a bit the most
difficult part of the technology
so the there were some others and the
the the the first one is that what we
Infuse is not really pure hepatocyte
it's just a liver sense suspension you
take the liver you isolate the cells
with collagenase and you infuse the kind
of soup of liver cells
the durability is unfortunately not as
long as a full liver transplantation so
after 18 months we started to have a
loss of the efficacy of the hepatocyte
transplantation
access to the little tissue is also of
course limited limiting the technology
you need more or less to have access to
one food liver to treat one recipient
and you do read few percent of enzyme
activity ideally you should reach 10 to
20 percent to have a really full control
of the metabolic disease access to the
portal vein as I mentioned is a bit
technically difficult
and in addition to that it is a full GMP
process so you need to have a GMP
facility to isolate hepatocyte
so
what we are doing in fact is now in the
it was in the tissue Bank of clinics and
Luke from University of Cuba we obtained
a human liver tissue and this human
liver tissue is perfused with
collagenase you have this soup of cells
and this soup of cells is then used to
transplant hepatocyte but what we have
done also as a quality control we have
plated these cells in vitro to obtain
culture of hepatocyte and what we did
observed which was quite interesting and
novel is that the hepatocyte Do Not
persist very long in culture but what we
did observe is the emergence of
fibroblastoid cells and these five
capacity cells take over and it becomes
a pure population of mesenchymal stem
cells but the hives on the liver so it's
specific mesenchymal stem cells that
could be then expanded in vitro and you
have this pure population of cells and
this was an invention because this was
not reported and described at that time
so we have characterized these liver
stem cells extensively and hope at that
time was of course that these cells
could replace the hepatocyte and that
you can expand these cells in large
quantities so that with one source of
liver tissue you can treat many many
patients so these cells are really
amazing because
these cells uh mscs they have the same
MSC markers than bone marrow or
adipocyte derived msc's but they have a
specific hepatocyte markers like asthma
and albumin there is no hematological
marker and no bigger remark so they are
unique and they are also unique because
they do Express simultaneously asthma
and albumin so this is not a cell that
you can find in the body this is a cell
that appears in the process of
cultivating the hepatocyte and the
progenitor cells and this was of course
the originality of the cell what was
also interesting is that the cell
because it's because derived from the
liver the cell does not express Class 2
hle and Class 2 HLA is an issue in terms
of immunos immuno
genicity and patients can develop
antibodies against two antigen which is
of course something you want to avoid
especially if the patient will require
organ transplantation later but the
benefit of cells coming from the liver
is that they do not express this class 2
HLA hladr
so
then of course we decided to use this
cell instead of the hepatocyte to treat
patients within bone alcohol of
metabolism and we did treat the first
child with this liver derived stem cells
this was again a child with
urea cycle disease and we could
demonstrate three to five percent
engraftment of these cells in the
patient and there was a stabilization of
ammonium concentration and decreased
aurotic acidoria which is also an
abnormal metabolites in this patient and
the patient did benefit from the
procedure with less decompensation
episodes
so what was also important is to
demonstrate that these cells when you
infuse these cells in the liver they do
persist in the liver and this was
beautiful beautifully shown with Indian
labeled cells as you can see on this
slide on the right panel the cell
reached the liver after five minutes but
that persists up to five days in the
liver and this is beautifully shown also
in this video
and in this video you can see the
progressive feeling of the liver with
the cells like if you would fill a
bottle with some some liquid you are
just feeding the liver of the patient
with cells so that is really amazing
especially also because these cells then
do not buy pasta liver they persist in
the liver they do not go out of the
liver and this patient
was the first one but we then started to
develop the spin-off company called
seleion and the aim was to treat a
patients with this disease with your
recycled disorders we have treated 24
patients and we could demonstrate safety
of the product this is always the first
thing you have to demonstrate in
clinical development but also that as
compared to the the
observational group there was an
improvement of ammonium level in the
blood of this patient and we had a very
sophisticated technique using C13
urea the synthesis in this patient we
could demonstrate denovo urea synthesis
following infusion of cells in this
patients however there were some
limitation first again the the level of
improvement was probably not sufficient
to compare with full liver
transplantation the second limitation
was this incaportal infusion as I
mentioned earlier it is technically
heavy for the patient you really need a
Interventional Radiology to find access
to the portal vein so you can do that
once twice but you cannot not do that
repeatedly so what we decided to do is
to ask a volunteer to receive the cells
by peripheral vein infusion a peripheral
vein infusion is really easy to apply
and what we could show which was really
amazing also is that after infusing the
cells in the in the peripheral vein the
cell will caused the lung but they will
not persist in the link this is the
normal circulation flow from your right
arm to the lungs and then to the lung
from the lungs to the Earth and from the
Earth to the liver and this cells have
made the way through the lungs and
through the Earth and they did reach the
river 60 percent the green at the line
shows that 60 percent of the cells
infused do heat the liver and persistent
the liver
the two
lines uh show uh showing the lung uh
very transient entrapment and then there
is this appearance of the cells from the
lung and the in-between lines are quite
interesting also you see the orange one
there is a peak and this peak
corresponds to the right lower panel
when you see when you see a hot spot of
cells focusing in a join because this
patient had joint inflammation so the
conclusion is that when you infuse the
cells by peripheral vein they do it
deliver they persist in the liver there
is some loss of cells in the reticular
endothelial system but there is also a
specific omig not only to the liver but
also to inflammatory side
and this is of course the next the next
development for this product because in
between
the concept has changed the cells are
not aimed to transdifferentiate into
hepatocyte they are not aimed to replace
fully the tissue but these cells have a
very strong and powerful
activity and this is more and more
demonstrator now including for this
specific cell a pastel has a strong
parakhine component the prod the cell
will produce cytokines and these other
kinds act in three different
way the first one is the strong
anti-inflammatory component thanks to
postagram glandine E2 Ido activity dgf
beta and this will fight inflammation in
the liver the second step is to release
a hepatocyte growth factor which will
add regenerating the liver tissue but
also spagos in one phosphate which will
block the leakage of the endothelial
barrier which is a component of chronic
liver disease and finally last but not
least TGF beta and metallopartise which
play an anti-fibotic hole in addition to
that because we originally treated a
genetic disease we are in an allogenic
setting which means that with one source
of tissue you can treat many many
patients and again it's quite easy to
apply know that we can Infuse the cell
by simple peripheral vein infusion
so what we are doing now is really the
cells are
cultivated in very large scale in a GMP
uh facility and they are stored in small
wires these wires are higher preserved
and then you can ship the cells in these
cryo container you can ship these cells
around the world they are stabilized in
this dry shipper for two weeks then you
just throw the cells reconstitute with a
diluent and Infuse the patient
so we decided then to treat patients
with strong and severe inflammation of
the liver and this is unfortunately the
case of many patients with chronic liver
disease
you can have chronic liver disease even
not knowing that for many reasons first
if you drink too much alcohol if you
have a fatty liver if you have
autoimmune disease or viral disease
there are many reasons to have a chronic
liver disease but you can feel very well
because you do not feel your liver and
then suddenly what happens is that when
the disease progresses suddenly you
become jaundice
uh the patient is yellow he develops
also ascitis which is uh fluid in the
abdomen and this is typically what is
called acute decompensation of the liver
so at that time it's only the liver but
because your liver is the central organ
of the body because of that other organ
will fail you will develop what is
called multi-organ failure
and this is what is called acute and
chronic liver failure it is a very
severe condition very life-threatening
if you see on this slide overall the
mortality at day 19 yellow is above 50
percent and there are different grade of
severity and the mortality is between 40
to 70 percent so very severe
life-threatening condition and this is
the one we have attempted to treat first
so
usually if you have a acute and chronic
liver failure you have joined this and
the mortality of this patient can even
reach in
more than 70 percent
especially if the patient have a
bilirubin elevated above five this is
again a jaundice
so we started to treat the most severe
patients because of course this was a
new treatment cell therapy so we would
not develop cell therapy for mild and
minor diseases
and the first clinical development is of
course a phase 2A study phased away is
mainly dedicated to demonstrate the
safety of your product it's always
safety first but also to try to see some
preliminary efficacy results and also to
have a dose findings
for your product and what was really
interesting in this uncontrolled study
phase two way is that we did observe in
a number of patient a decrease of
jaundice decrease of jaundice but also
decrease of the mild score the Melt
score is the score that gives you
priority
for transplantation
and a number of patients that
Improvement of the Melt Improvement of
child use score Improvement of binary
Bean but also the two last panels show
Improvement of inflammation which is the
mechanism of action of the cells CRP was
decreasing and leukocyte count was also
decreasing so this was quite encouraging
first we have shown safety and we have a
signs of preliminary efficacy so we went
back to the regulatory authorities with
a protocol designed at this time to
establish the proof of concept that this
EPA stem cell can indeed
treat patients with
such a severe life-threatening condition
in addition we also could see that on
the long term there was an improvement
in the function of the liver and this is
albumin synthesis and on the right that
the kidney function was maintained
what is usually the case in this patient
is that due to the liver disease there
is Progressive kidney impairment kidney
function impairment and now the
designers the of the clinical trial
is a placebo-controlled study because we
want to bring this proof of concept we
treat severe patients patients with
aggregine patients who are persistent
acute and chronic liver failure which
means that the must be diagnosed with
the disease but we treat only the ones
who do not recover spontaneously then
they receive two infusion of the epistem
two-thirds of the patient receives the
product one third received Placebo and
the primary endpoint is at day 90 we
want to obtain an improvement of the
survival of this patient so this is an
ongoing trial and we of course hope to
deliver good results by mid of next year
but it's not the unique possibility
because as I mentioned the cells and ETA
stem is also fighting inflammation
one huge disease around the world is
Nash Nash
is non-alcolex theater hepatitis it is a
complication of nothing
is non-alcoholic fatty liver disease and
that time you just have a fatty liver
but then suddenly and we don't know
precisely why inflammation comes on the
top of this fatty liver and this is
sterato hepatitis this is a chronic
liver disease which is becoming now the
first cause of liver transplantation in
adults so what we want to do and what we
have just published now uh is that paper
stem is able to migrate to inflammatory
side to secrete these anti-inflammatory
molecule and this will help decreasing
the inflammation in the liver and the
hope is to revert nafldi to revert
Nashville to stop the inflammatory
component and to avoid the progression
of a stator hepatitis to circles and the
animal model was just published
these days in cells and we are of course
developing a clinical development
program for this indication so what is
nice with uh cell therapy is that it is
a cargo it's not one use unique
medication it's multiple medication
contained in a cargo you deliver the
cargo to the tissue and the different
mechanism of action will then act in
Synergy and that's why we have a
pipeline of different indications the
first one is acute and connective
failure we are in this proof of concept
tile we hope to deliver the
demonstration of efficacy by mid of next
year and then we we can extend the
clinical development to Nash acute
decompensation alcoholic liver disease
also just to treat any patient who has
inflammatory liver disease and of course
MSC therapy as La has been uh
in the two in the Years 2000 there was a
height for MSC therapies but then there
was some disappointment because at that
time the The View was to replace tissue
but now there is a huge comeback of this
technology because now we know that the
mechanism of action is parakhine
anti-inflammatory regenerative and this
is really why we think that we can now
bring that like true that is still
expected in MSC therapies first because
of this strong parkine component because
we are in an allergenic setting so the
logistic is quite easy with one source
of tissue you treat many many patients
because this epistem come from the liver
and the return to the liver and they
have low endogenicity very simple
peripheral vein infusion no need anymore
to do in her portal in Fusion in between
we have an outstanding safety profile we
started to treat children within one era
of metabolism but now more than 100
patients have been infused with perfect
safety profile we have this preliminary
efficacy data
and now we we are in this proof of
concept study with the green line from
the data and safety monitoring board to
pursue the study without any change and
of course also we are in a life-saving
indication there is no alternative
treatment so there is a highly unmet
medical need
so this is currently the story of uh at
the end academic research translational
research but then of course the need to
develop a biotech company which is due
to develop the product and to organize
the clinical trial for bringing this
product at the end to the patient in
need and I would like to thank of course
my Hospital Saint Luke Hospital my
university university of lufa and a cell
ion which is the biotech company
developing the product for the patients
thank you very much for your attention